welcome back will I get a makeover after
AI takes over the rapid growth of
artificial intelligence tools has
experts predicting that nearly 90
percent of the internet will be AI
generated by 2025. 90 will be created by
robots that's almost on par with CNN
insiders say that generative AI like
chat gbt barely scratches the surface of
future applications
translation calmly run for your lives
but now some users of chat gbt claim it
exhibits left-leaning bias for example
it refuses to tell jokes about climate
change or write a story about why drag
queen's Story Hour is bad
phew Gutfeld writers are safe
[Laughter]
to take over Health Care too this is
amazing
chat gbt recently passed all three parts
of the U.S medical licensing exam during
a research experiment
Marcus Welby might turn into Marcus
welded
[Laughter]
anyone no
I wanted to make sure that was the worst
joke ever told
as machine learning accelerates AI tools
are tackling all forms of media with
ease which means they'll eventually come
for my job look they already replaced
Jimmy Fallon there was Alpha
this latest fairy it might be the best
it's xbb Point 1.5 the good news some
enterprising engineers at did already
captured my Essence in digital form
and here he is
so AI Greg thanks so much for being here
you must have a lot to say what's on
your mind
[Music]
hmm
wow this is really good
I could see you can change your form at
will what are your thoughts on climate
change
poop everywhere poop on you
wow it's like I could live forever so
what's your take on the economy
well thank you for stopping by AI Greg
yeah
see I I don't even have to work anymore
all right tires I kind of know what does
your AI look like Sebastian Gorka
could be coach relief Factor has made me
a stronger man it's like and zielinski
had an AI baby
I want to write a check but okay I know
it bugs you Tyrus but we have to let's
just consider the huge FAA outage of
last week was human error not software
and we talked about remember I said like
if I was with you finish your point and
then I'm gonna give you money about the
fact that if you get all the information
in the world on medicine in one place
the prediction that the machine will
make will be more accurate than any
doctor unless what we found and what the
reason why it bothered me so much about
the the drag story was
it was based off the programmers
feelings and influences so if they're
programming and we say we want to make
sure that we reduce medication
distribution by 70 and that's the
program therefore the analysis will be
like oh you don't need this you don't
need this now I'm like I don't want an
AI lawyer anymore because if they're
like listen we want to settle we want to
settle six percent of course so the AIS
will find ways to settle even though
it's against your best interest because
yes the AI is it but it's the programmer
that we have to worry about so whatever
the programmers issues are the AI will
follow through on and that's actually uh
uh makes me rethink this cat because
what if the AI is operating for the
greater good and not for your good
because that's also that's off if the if
the machine is so hyper intelligent that
it's thinking about the future of the
universe and the future of the world he
might find he AI he might find it
entirely meaningless with your problem
as a lawyer defending you might say yeah
we lower the costs here over time we
will save a trillion dollars what do you
what say you human being
yeah I I mean I said that when we were
talking about the AI lawyers that it's
they might not be in your best interest
uh because it can't be objective because
the programmers are human beings when it
comes to journalism though I'm not sure
if it'll ever really take off because
what is journalism if you can't you know
send a bunch of hateful emails to the
person who wrote the article yes that's
like that's like a huge part of the
internet these days yeah so I think that
there's certain you know
you you can't equal it with objective
because humans are never objective and
if they create the software the software
is not going to be objective I guess but
then I to argue against that we don't
have biased toasters or biased cars lost
they said no joke rated by human beings
but the toaster and decide and I get six
to eight right yes
what if the toaster was your lawyer it'd
be a cup of water on toaster lawyer
toaster lawyer coffee machine is sexist
how so because the espresso machine when
I try to use it it doesn't work but when
cam tries to use it it does and why is
it Mr sexist yeah Mr Coffee right sexist
yeah and how come I say I want a
Darkness on my toaster my toaster is
like no you're gonna have it a little
lighter
I'm listen you guys always bust my chops
about this I'm terrified of this AI
unplug it all unplug it all it when it
when when the AI starts going no I don't
wanna you know you're like hey could you
write something about trans or woke and
the AI is like no don't think I will I'm
busy about to launch nukes
unplug it all well what you're talking
about is
um unconscious thinking it's like when
AI is much like a meter Mage you ever
talk to a meter maid that's uncar that's
unconscious uh thinking they have to do
this thing they have to do this thing
and you and if they say they're not
going to do it they're not going to do
it and that's the scary part about AI is
if it's got super intelligence it's
going to find a way to do what it wants
yes and you know what it's going to do
the weather I
I can't hate to tell you they're going
to be more accurate
oh it's all about the presentation yeah
I guess so I mean I've seen some pretty
hot sex dolls what am I saying what are
you saying I don't know my book again
yes I am that's in chapter eight
Then Greg revealed the sex doll from
underneath his locker I call this Coach
Johnson
put the book down guys
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else